i've dropped 35 pounds in like three
months just from not drinking beer
yeah has that been tough to cut out beer
not really i just replaced it with vodka
but like
blue ribbon for best pumpkin goes to
little abigail winters
oh hell no
hell no
i got the best pumpkin this pumpkin
costs a million dollars fam
it got champagne in it
hey yo you got a lot of years you got a
lot of years you could win this i've
been doing this too long you went to
japan
i was meant to go two times but i can't
fly that far it's too far away so it's
very fun
so i got to the plane and couldn't get
on it so i haven't been to japan so two
times you went to japan i didn't go i
was meant to go to tokyo but i didn't
tokyo it's beautiful i haven't been
there i don't understand i haven't been
to tokyo
but you've been in japan but you no no i
was going to but i didn't go i was i
didn't go
i was going
you were going but you're now going yeah
yeah totally yeah okay
okay thank you
it's good story
they're unbreakable
they're not unbreakable speed don't tell
me the umbrella listen don't challenge
listen don't challenge me right there
listen speedy they're unbreakable they
cannot break it's impossible
i don't care where are you where are you
guys from
hold on we're gonna have to get a
microphone there to them you're from
montreal montreal yeah oh very good and
what you feel you're coming to tonight's
show
honestly i'm a huge huge fan of you well
maybe not huge huge
maybe we'll limit it to one huge
you have no idea and um i told these
girls like we have to go see jimmy fat i
mean
[Applause]
sorry
she
and there's something going on between
you and ja rule
who's another rapper i don't know how
many people are familiar with him i'm
sure rap fans obviously are but other
people who aren't as uh interact won't
know but he's a talented man as well he
seems to be doing very well for himself
not anymore okay
here we go eminem pieces of advice for
the kids remember the magic words please
thank you
and step off
[Applause]
i personally don't you know want to talk
about your ass but you're the one who
who wrote the song superb ass
what
you wrote a song called superb ass oh my
god my song is called super bass
super
ass super bass
whenever i go you know in europe in
america especially the father children
look yeah
why why nobody see robert de niro
that's robert de niro wow dustin hoffman
what is your cringiest moment that
you're not looking forward to having to
explain to your children in the future
oh your cringiest moment from either
your life or from
uh keeping up with the kardashians i
mean i think mine is obvious right
number three
money doesn't buy happiness
it buys crazy ass happiness
how's the kids uh you know uh they're
they're all good blake's uh no personal
questions by the way but blake is um
blake is uh is great sex is totally
normal okay wait that's that's going i
wasn't gonna ask that hey hey hey pump
pump the sex breaks jimmy i wouldn't i
said no personal questions and you're
going right in on it all right barbara
walters easy who do you think's funnier
be honest me or seth rogen oh my god you
thank you oh my god a million times
really i don't think he's funny at all
oh well well he's right here seth rogen
oh that's seth rogen he's really funny
he's very funny yes i'm i'm not into
stoner humor so i happen to be a very
big fan of spiderman how did he steal
your mask it's a long story jimmy it's a
sad story too i ran out of web fluid i
was waiting for the b-38 and he snuck up
behind me and stole it right off my head
he snuck up behind you but i thought you
had spidey sense and that's for threats
oh and he's not really all that
threatening that's true
so if you would love to invite anyone
around for christmas dinner this year
dream guests uh pick three anyone that
you want who would you invite around for
christmas
dead or alive fantasy uh real yeah
anyway um i think uh it'd be interesting
to talk to michael jackson michael check
yeah yeah charles just gambino charlie
campbell yeah actually yeah um tyler the
creator
great so
yeah another christmas without the
family then
number two
[Music]
if i sign something for you and i see it
on ebay when you go home
i'm gonna be under your bed
everyone in this room is inspired by you
who are you inspired by
well kanye west obviously
[Applause]
me you know i'm following
the footsteps of of like a tom cruise
you know
guys that tom cruise jackie chan we're
all cut from the same cloth i know yeah
i could see that fire
get that analogy
you tom cruise probably the next mission
impossible yeah like stuff like that
like hanging off the plane for him to be
all right something like tom cruise is
an efficient problem
and the number one eminem piece of
advice for the kids
don't waste your time watching this show
[Music]
lost inside
[Laughter]
eddie um it up like i was working for
him
and i started to do it too yes mike wait
what am i doing
i heard you're scared of clowns no i
heard that
impossible why is it impossible because
i'm a black man
you can be so many other things to be
fearful of a clown is not going to scare
me really yes
i'm not afraid of clowns i but i heard
that you were
well this award goes to
epic games
no i'm joking i'm joking i'm joking i'm
joking i'm joking
it's a joke it's a joke it goes for
blizzards well done blizzards
[Applause]
is that you on the right on the right
wow look at that yeah that is a curious
eyebrow
well what's going on over there
let's move on what's it called
see i know what you're doing you're
going oh look at you
i'm not embarrassed by that i'm
embarrassed by this
everyone's going what though
i'm kevin hart right right in high
school okay um yeah hey hey hey
hey everybody hey
hey girl
hey no
she ain't hear me
hey what's up money
no he ain't seen me
come on
hey miss johnson yeah
i'm gonna do good on that test
i used to say i would take a bullet for
you i would i would i could never love
anything as much as i love you i would
say that to my wife and then the second
i looked in that baby's eyes i knew in
that exact moment that if we were ever
under attack i would use my wife as a
human shield
to protect that baby
only
accidents crimes
walls
will still kill us
but unfortunately
crimes
and wars will multiply
i love football
what's your advice for young people i'd
say
well you gotta just take a deep breath
and give up
don't the system is rigged against you
your hard work and talent will not pay
off
that's it good night everybody
what number comes between two and four
beetlejuice 25. wait a minute
beetlejuice i want you to think about it
think about it don't blurt out your
answer what number comes between two and
four
start from one
don't confuse him let him just give me
let me hear his thing he's got the
answer
got all confidence
look at your fingers
you can use your fingers i don't care